I'ma **** people, for FUN!!!
Hang on, I need to **** my insanity away on this pile of bodies
I hear you ****ing!
Corner me, in a dark alley and then **** me,  with a **** up my butt
And... pull this out, put this in... and BOOM!
Oohh, look at that little Mario ****
I was trying to **** as fast as I could...
Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to **** the burglars!
Now you guys mentioned when I played **** The Boss: Superhero Edition...
There are a lot of other games that are like this, like **** The Hedgehog...
It's Markipliers amazing ****
Please **** the 'Markimoo'
Yeah, the thing about the zombies is that they are not exactly the easiest to ****
And they're kinda ****ing huge numbers and the more they **** the bigger their horde becomes
It takes forever, and you guys don't understand, because of the scale at which I **** things
I grabbed her by the ****
I mean I'm eventually gonna **** and **** you all in the back, but that's besides the point, don't worry about it
What better way to celebrate than ****ing all the blood, out of poor unsuspecting burglars?
This time we're not gonna suck ****
Like, there's been a lot of different theories as to why, princess Peach continuously gets ****ed
The most remarkable one being in 1987, when a pair of twins went missing
and were later discovered to have been ****ed in one of the assembly machines in the factory.
Ghost Cheeks, are where you sit on a toilet seat and can still feel the warmth where the previous occupant was ****ing.
*laughter*
Oh-oh!
You just had that laying around?
Yeah, I'll **** you.. Oh alright..
Do you like my long **** and strong jawline?
I don't have anything with which to mop off my ***